you have a drink alone
so there's a two kinds of alone one is
alone like at a bar oh we there's other
people but they're strangers right
they're kind of like out there
keep going yeah don't walk me through
all the alarms and then I'll tell you
the rest there's all kinds there's all
kinds of there's a alone on a train
we're transporting stuff
and then there's just the loan in uh in
an empty home or a hotel room hotel and
it's Sunday night Sunday night and
you're packing your bag and you got a
flight at six a.m yeah but Roadhouse is
on and you're like [__] so you go down
to the front desk and go is the bar
still open and they go yeah can I order
something to take to my room sure how
about six Heinekens six Heinekens yeah
my wife wanted one too she's not up
there you murdered her and you just say
to yourself I'm just getting six so that
if I have four I just know I have two
extra ones and then you go through six
and you're like oh man I'm not done yet
dude I've drank in every alone scenario
you can possibly think of I've drank uh
I've drank alone in a helicopter with a
dude who didn't know I was drinking uh
he was I was like kind of drinking here
and he's like absolutely not and then I
poured it into a flask and opened it and
drank it and he's like dude we're in a
[__] helicopter you don't think I
smell that the best alone drinking you
can ever do in my opinion now we're
getting the Weeds on it is alone behind
someone's back
what do you mean like when they don't
know you're drinking but you're drinking
hmm like uh like Christmas shopping uh
and your wife says all right let's all
split up and you go cool and it's like
it's like 11 o'clock on a Sunday and
they just opened that bar by the
elevator in the Beverly Center and you
just sneak over and you go hey man
can I get a double Jack on the Ross
Oxford like sure and you just haven't
you just go let's just and then you're
off and then you're like yeah yeah and
then you just little sneak one sneak it
and sneak it and then buzz and nobody
knows and then your wife's like wait
have you been drinking like
yeah I'm drinking by myself in a [__]
mall yeah on Christmas how sad do you
think I am and then you go yeah I am